[Music]
foreign
your leading parliament's work on this
information and foreign interference on
European democracy I wanted to focus
today more on the disinformation part of
your work you have already prepared two
sets of recommendations for the European
Union on how to deal with this matter
and I understand again this process you
met with many independent journalists
legislators from foreign countries U.N
Representatives what did you learn from
this meetings is there a pattern or
specific challenges in Europe when it
comes to this information
we we have learned a lot from them but
the the general observation what I can
make is not very optimistic because the
the speed with which the digital reality
develops
is so high that the legislative protests
is lagging behind because technology
goes faster than the legislative process
as one of the experts said the situation
what we are discussing currently today
it's already yesterday
so and we cannot pre-amp to what's going
to happen absolutely absolutely
absolutely uh and and secondly uh what
is very difficult uh for Democratic
countries and we are a democratic
countries that we are very open in our
system and those third countries
who uh
have a line interests they are
manipulating with our freedoms to
intervene with our freedom we can still
learn from the past and we sing in
America that this information has feared
has helped fill in uh violence I still
remember the things of people storming
the capital in the United States and the
year after people storming the Congress
in Brazil as well what is the risk that
this sort of violence happens also in
Europe
first of all I have to say that I'm
quite optimistic about Europe in that
sense because if we are speaking about
even unbelievable events in the U.S
Congress or in Brazil that was the
consequence of for quite a long time
a spreads of different
harmful information which raised the
tension in society and and divides the
society and there is part of that lies
with the president of the United States
I should say that in Europe
maybe that because of the union we are
trained more to be
inclined for compromise culture
and our politicians are more responsible
I can't name any politician who would
appeal donation just attack the
parliament but also why I'm so
optimistic that we really understand the
challenge of the problem and we are
trying to adopt the legislation we have
a digital Service Act which is dealing
with illegal content and which puts also
the responsibility for platforms to
assess the risks and also to control
the content which is distributed in the
social networks and and secondly
we strengthened the first attempt to
propose for the platforms a sort of
agreement or behavior which is called
democracy uh defense package the first
attempt was called code of conduct
but it's not Flawless because it's
voluntarily the biggest platforms all
agreed and they are trying to implement
but there are a multitude of small the
servers and platforms who are not part
of that agreement and some of them are
quite aggressive
so we have to to find a way how also
impose on them this behavior for in the
two reports that you prepare for this
Parliament you mentioned that social
network platforms are not doing their
part you're not doing enough and I want
to highlight that your two reports one
was last year and the other one just
been adopted this week does it mean that
in 12 months nothing has evolved nothing
has happened to improve that is the
question about uh
stenciling of toolboxes what we already
are having and the most important is
that we have to get to to
understand how the algorithms are
working that they have to be more
transparent there has to be
accessibility for uh in for researchers
and also for fact Checkers social
networks I think the most important
tools which
Parliament already adopted is digital
service act because it's dealing with
illegal content and imposing to social
platforms certain obligations they have
to follow and one of our recommendations
is that actions to counter this
information should go hand in hand with
actions to promote free speech in other
fundamental rights this might seem
contradictory could you explain to us
how uh fighting against this information
helps promoting free speech and vice
versa
sounds quite contradictory but this is
something what I understand profoundly
by all my experience why we need to
counter this information because this
information appeals to psychologically
to to human beings
by
serving on menu what he wants to hear
and then he bases his decisions and
understanding of reality on this bubble
in which he is included because of likes
he is making and that is the job done by
algorithms
why we need to promote truly's free
speech and information because that
information is based on fact
and by providing the the
a truthful picture of any of problems we
are providing uh freedom of speech
Freedom of Information what you mention
about algorithms make me think of one
thing there are some psychological
studies that say that people tend to
believe what they want to believe
actually and I guess that people and
institutions interested in sowing this
information
they they operate over that they take
profit of that how can we Face this
problem this problem is as old as
ancient assuming nature yeah that's
really very human nature and the
difference between this information few
centuries ago and this information
currently is exactly the quantity of
this information the instruments with
which it could be dispersed around the
world and the speed with which it's
distributed but as I mentioned exactly
because there is micro targeted this
information
for instance 2016 campaign of President
Trump was precisely built on that and
that is the year when also the
Democratic countries we realized the
danger of that intern intervention
intervention
and interference in Democratic processes
but the the only way of how we can help
to
build resilience
I think it goes through education and
here again we are facing a problem we
can recommend and suggest but a system
of education is entirely in
responsibility of member states and are
they doing an awful media literacy there
are quite many different
programs and projects to help to deal
with media literacy but I still think
that we need
more systematic approach and to to
allocate more financial resources for
that because media literacy
still have loopholes
as to very young people and also to the
senior citizens who are out of of these
uh programs and tools they are not so
um
skillful to deal with them
my my conviction if we speak generally
about all this enormous complexes that
that is a mistake that we are dealing
with digital revolution in the
compartments I think the basic problem
that we don't
have complex approach to that and if I'm
looking in the future I think that we
are facing a complete change of yeah of
reality with artificial intelligence and
which will require the change of
practically everything and then there is
also the the question of definition like
who decides what is this information or
is true and what is the lie you have
asked on your reports for the EU to step
up action to come up with an
international common definition of this
information like some countries have for
hate crimes or for racism why is this
important to have a common definition of
of this information you have to have
common language you have to know
what that word contains but this is
extremely difficult uh difficult task to
find the common uh definition for this
information I went to un in with the
delegation of our committee and we
discuss it in different departments and
also in different with different
representatives from different member
State states of United States United
Nations and it just showed
uh
what are the difficulties for
countries with the
in the European Union it's quite easy
values yeah we have the set of values
but these values are not uh values for
entire community of United Nations there
are also countries
in which
democracy
is let's call it control democracy which
is a sort of manipulation of the
elections then there are autocracies and
there are also dictatorships and for
them this information is ideological
tool to assure the control over the
country and that's why UAP and Union has
to take lead in that and at least agree
on determine of this information among
ourselves on several other difficult
problems we have been the the Setters of
language the Setters of terminology the
Setters of of Trend and and then
gradually it is adopted by other
institutions
a new reporter also introduced the
concept of a high-risk Third Country
what is this about and which countries
are you talking about
all our relationship with the world
outside from European Union is based on
the country agnostic approach which
means that we are treating all countries
equally but in the same time when we
know that all those countries are not
equal
uh if we look we are looking from the
point of different uh objective criteria
and high risk third countries I I'm
proposing that we treat them according
to objective criteria which could be and
I will read them for instance what could
be potential criteria it could be
activity of foreign interference which
is fact checked and as evidence
stealing of intellectual property
systematic stealing of uh of
intellectual property from Union and its
member states one of criteria for me
which is important consistent violation
of human rights in the country for
instance in the case of Russia
the blatant
revision of international order by
aggressive act of aggression so you
mentioned Russia China are there other
countries that we can make oh yeah
already there are we can speak about
Iran particularly uh there are multitude
of countries but none of them can
achieve such a volume of interference
and diversity of interference as Russia
and China so those are the main ones
yeah
coming back to the European elections we
are one year away from the European
elections in your report you also
mentioned that Russia is massively
investing on a financing political
parties in Democratic countries how can
this affect the the information scenario
in Europe you are touching one of the
the issues which are absolutely vital
for the existence of our democracy
because democracy is an open system
as soon as there is a hostile uh Third
Country coming in with its own interests
financing
so-called governmental non-governmental
organizations on or proxy foundations
which are used to strengthen their
interests which are used to divide our
societies then we have to protect
ourselves I think the one of the most
important
parts of Elections is to strengthen the
Electoral instruments which is the
voting system the counting of votes
Etc secondly it's uh media media Freedom
pact which provides Independence for
media which is protected against
manipulative media which supports
investigative journalism because
journalists investigative journalists
are those who can follow that dirty
money how it is the in a very covered
way
seeping into the union and complicating
the normal Democratic process of course
also as we before we were speaking about
media literacy about
fact checking about the resilience
against
manipulation and fake news all that is
important he also alerted that there and
perhaps other countries are likely to
step up their misleading narratives
against Europe in the wake of the
elections to try and influenciate the
European elections from next year and
there's some media reports that Russia
has tripled the investment the budget
for propaganda about the Ukrainian war
and that part of this money and this
propaganda are also to be spread in
other countries not only internally in
Russia how can Europe oppose this
Warfare this communication Warfare
First Steps were very uh
Speedy a way closed
Sputnik and Russia Today these were
broadcasting in many countries and in
many languages and that was I would say
a very strong signal to Russia that we
are not going to accept
that sort of disinformation instrument
in the European Union
the problem is that Russia Today Sputnik
and other media they immediately
switched to the areas so where we have
no power
to forbid to social uh media Network so
people could still go around yeah
Telegram and Tick Tock and
Facebook whatever uh that is one of the
the problems uh we also have to replace
with proactive content
which is attractive and interesting for
those who are the consumers who have
been consumers of Russia Today and
Sputnik and this is something what we
are trying uh currently to do and to
conclude this interview we're having
this conversation here in the house of
European history which is a museum
managed by the European Parliament here
in Brussels what is a history's role on
this information does it help countering
this information or does it help
promoting it how do you see it I would
say that for years and years we were
quite quite indifferent to the
historical truths and to historical
Justice and it created a very beneficial
platform for Kremlin for Putin
to
manipulate with historical fact to
introduce their own interpretations of
them
and look
where we are now because
Kremlin justifies their attack
aggressive attack
non-provoked attack to Ukraine
with complete historical uh
money manipulation of fact stating that
Ukraine never has been independent
country that it is not a nation
and it shows how important it is that we
are scrupulous when we are dealing with
history and historical facts for
instance deportations I'm born in
Siberia by deported parents and in this
Museum I presented as as
a gift a letter of my grandfather from
Gulag I would say until the entrance of
our countries in the European Union
communism and the kinds of Communism
were not really on the agenda of of
Western countries but for instance next
month in the European Parliament we will
have for the first time
the official commemoration ceremony
for deportations of 1941. now we are
or 30 years after this Idol curtain fell
first time that will ceremony will
happen
why I am speaking about it because from
the occupied territories of Ukraine
there are more than 20 000 children
deported Russian Duma adopted a law
which allows
urgent adoption of Ukrainian children
they are deprived of their national
identity
they are converted into
someone or they are not and it just
shows that history repeats itself if we
do not strictly stand for truth we
accept silence but because this is more
comfortable then it's it's very easy to
repeat it again
[Music]